Jake says how has your study of
consciousness affected your worldview
and your priorities in life have you
changed your priorities based on which
question and I'm not sure I have a good
and interesting answer at least I'll
tell you what it helps me do is how it
helps me to like not take things so
seriously honestly like for me realizing
like yeah like oh I get these like
really anxious feelings sometimes for no
reason but then that causes me to be
like oh there must be something I should
be anxious about right now what is it
you know and I'm really good at finding
stuff - yeah but when I get those
feelings I you know as I've gotten older
I realize and for understanding because
I was raised like super religious - like
now I'm not really religious at all
indefinitely I mean I'm still a little
woowoo I guess but not nearly as much as
what I was you know but back in my early
20s but but because of understanding you
know the the the scientific viewpoint
from you know looking at consciousness
or looking at freewill yeah I mean for
me it just helps me to not take things
as seriously it doesn't mean that you're
know I'm gonna live on the street I mean
you know and like and ignore all my
priorities but yeah but yeah I actually
appreciate having the like do your book
consciousness totally help me again like
just take that serious level and take it
down a notch well and I think that is
that's partly the experience of awe and
that is I mean that that was the only
thing I could really think of an answer
to that question I'm not a religious
person haven't ever been a religious
person but I consider my I'm very
careful about using this word but I
always have considered myself to be very
spiritual and part of that living with
that spiritual component is a lot of
that comes to me actually from science
and from this experience of awe so yes I
think it does it definitely gives me
that answering the question i I don't
think of myself as even a spiritual
person if anything I'm more religious
than I am spiritual because I actually
all I really mean by that is like I
appreciate ritual talk about a word that
people use a zillion different ways we
may not
all right you must be using the word the
same way yeah there it's go ahead I
think the way you use the word is like
to mean numinous or something like that
actually it's funny I was working I was
thinking about this recently because of
all these conversations I'm having and I
also some months ago I'm there's a
philosopher Thomas Metzinger who's who's
wonderful who's recently become a friend
and he wrote a piece that he sent to me
that I actually posted on my web site
that I think is great and I'm forgetting
the title of it but I thing to do with
intellectual honesty spirituality and
intellectual honesty okay it's fantastic
and he gives the this definition I
actually have it in my notes if you want
the actual actual wording but he says he
thinks of spirituality or he declares
that spirituality is not the opposite of
science so shoot I'm not going to get it
right sorry no the he declares that
spirituality is the opposite of religion
that's what he says mmm-hmm and he
describes it kind of in a scientific
context and an ethical context but
really a search for truth that at its
core it's a search for truth not belief
but for truth and he gives a beautiful
explanation for how he arrives at this
but I realized myself as I was thinking
what do I mean by spiritual and what
what do I think of when when I value
spirituality and for me it's similar to
what he's talking about but I kind of
came up with this description of a state
of staring into the unknown
while seeking truth and experiencing an
intimate connection to the universe at
large it's like these three components
of facing the unknown wanting looking
for truth and there's there's a
component of feeling connected that your
we are in fact a part of this universe
what whatever is going on at a
fundamental level and so experiencing
that connection within the context of
not having all the answers hmm and
wondering
the thing that I appreciate about
religion is the ritual you know some of
my closest friends are are like pastors
and like I just people I grew up with
and their children especially I think
actually but yeah and I think you know
it to a great extent we've we've lost
quite a bit of of ritual especially as
we've commoditized and turned everything
we've turned love into a transaction
either diamonds are forever and and we
we've we've commodified essentially
everything and in doing so we've lost a
sense of of community yeah yeah deep
connection to each other we've replaced
our you know if we just had an
earthquake here recently and like if
your house were to fall down you've you
weave commoditized that right because
like well just right I've got write a
check every month an insurance company
and they replace it whereas before was
like you're a house fell down well the
community comes together and if you
rebuild the house I'm not sure that was
better
I'm teasing you yeah but ya know there's
more money for community yes because
we're talking about dreams I had this
dream last night
tell me if this is a term that I made up
or if like I tweeze this from somewhere
I think Freud would say you wanna have
sex with your father post-industrial
angst yeah I mean I've never heard that
term I don't know I woke up it was like
an essay title it's I woke up and it was
post-industrial teenage angst because
the dream I was having was about I don't
even know if was my brother or sister
but they were like wrapped up in Twitter
and like and mine I don't know why this
popped up but I woke up thinking
post-industrial teenage angst but then I
was like what doesn't have to be limited
to teenagers like post-industrial inks
but I think that's weird I mean what I'm
thinking of is post-industrial angst
adds to the point of like why we are
losing this community well Chris Ryan
has a book coming out called civilized
to death and you know the the thesis of
that is like we've we've become so
civilized that we're no longer civilized
like it's
it's a continuum right there's there's
probably balance like of course I don't
want to go back to hunter-gatherers and
and everyone fearing for their life
around every every corner we definitely
have and I think I think you're right
that religion has always provided things
that are extremely important and this is
something I think a lot about because I
didn't grow up religious and it's it's
you know I'm mostly focused on the ways
in which it divides people just given
given my work but all of these things
that it's provided I think are extremely
important and I'm more more aware of
this as my as I have kids and I'm you
know raising them in the world ritual
rites of passage celebrations all of
those things are incredibly important
and our moments for us to be connected
and to share our lives with each other
and it's it's hard to find yeah I find
that I don't have the same beliefs as a
lot of my religious friends but I have
very similar values yeah and it actually
it makes me it makes me actually want to
attend like a church service not because
I want to like well I want to affirm
their beliefs but because I feel like
there is a sense of community that it
not even just sense of community I feel
like I have a good sense of community I
I lack the communal rituals in life this
is the most ritual thing that I have in
my life is every Tuesday we even just
that like meeting every Sunday or
whatever day it is like having a weekly
intention based place to meet and and
reconnect with what you care about to
recenter yourself to talk about ethical
questions to talk about big things
you're facing in your life to have
someone wise stand up and speak to
everyone and get everyone kind of on the
same page about remembering what our
values out are and it's why religion
works so well it's for all those reasons
it's like you've got a group of people
who are genuinely looking out for each
other's interests and you have the same
beliefs and you're you have those
rituals and I mean if I had a better
answer to religion I'd give it but like
you know when it comes I think yeah I
don't think we're there yet but we're
we're kind of we're kind of getting
there and I think I think the problem
Ryan is when when the beliefs trumped
the values and Soleil where it's like I
believe gay people shouldn't write it
Marian I liked this community more than
I like my values so yeah it's almost
like yeah yeah and so there are there
are times where where I we don't want
our beliefs to trample our our values I
think the beliefs are the values of the
destination and the beliefs of the path
to get there the Ryan and I have
different beliefs with different
political beliefs we have different
religious beliefs but I think we would
use different paths to get to the same
destination ultimately
you